live on LinkedIn and you're taking the
questions from let's think about that
ready go
what episode number everybody this is
gary vay-ner-chuk so three 22 of the
askgaryvee show
I'm excited here because this gentleman
I've been able to interact with multiple
times I'm always a fan of people that
are the deep practitioner an expert in
their craft you know I kind of been very
narrow in my career whether it's been
wine or marketing or now sports cards
and and this young man's expertise falls
into a place that I think is gonna make
everybody who's watching and listening
stand up because we have all interacted
in the hotel ecosystem also I wanna give
a huge shout out to everybody's watching
right now on LinkedIn live we're just
starting that platform and as a matter
of fact today I made a I made a pretty
easy structure which is I want to really
let Faisal speak for five or ten minutes
about the things he cares about but then
I really want to help a lot of people
because I think we're good at like
reacting I know you're speed it matches
mine and so we'll take some questions
we're gonna take those questions from
LinkedIn so if you have a question on
LinkedIn please put in your phone number
and we will give you a call that's once
you introduce yourself to the
vaynernation yeah vaynernation what's
going on Gary thinks so he's fun be back
in New York City love this place miss it
you know but Vegas is not a bad place to
live at either no yeah so Faisal sub
Levon president CEO Bona tell exclusive
travel we're one of the largest
distributors of luxury hotel rooms b2b
so we sell to say in Expedia and then
they sell to the end consumer it's the
easiest way for people to understand so
at the luxury end there's the the room
then there's you in between the room and
Expedia middleman or a glorified
middleman and so what we do is we go to
a hotel we provide basically turnkey
solutions to distribute in over seventy
three different countries so we work
very closely as a strategic marketing
and distribution partner hence the
reason you know we
we work with the the vaynermedia team as
well yes you know in order to create
awareness and give an authentic lens
into those properties but besides being
an operator like myself there's been a
growth within your personal brand
through content things that nature how
has that been tell me that journey yeah
I mean for for me you know I think
you've spoken about this before you know
I had investment group who said why do
you need to be on Instagram LinkedIn
Facebook or any of these social
platforms creating awareness I told them
whether you're in b2b b2c you have to
have a social media presence it's the
way to be it's the way of the future and
if not your business is basically
irrelevant and so that's have you found
that producing content at scale and
putting yourself out there has created a
scenario that has led to business
development yeah I mean it's a top of
the funnel biz dev tool period and a
story end of story we get inbound
somebody who's in and you consider you
are you guys in the SAS business are you
in the services business to broker
business like how do you even look at
the highest level how do you position
your code yeah I mean for us it's
there's technology that enables
distribution of inventory you know SAS
is not really what I would call it
service I mean it is in a lot of in a
lot of ways the services business
because you have people who are
traveling the stuff goes wrong all the
time and so we have to distribute solve
the problems exedra
yep what kind of kid were you so it's
funny you say that so you know growing
up in a small town Lodi California I
think you empathy wines has a couple I
know Mettler family says yeah his mom
Brandon Miller was mom was my swim mom
no way definitely a connection to Lodi
there yeah so I grew up my mom came from
a large family but we're extremely poor
my father immigrated from the Middle
East so he came with $100 in his pocket
and then was just a born entrepreneur
and so for me constantly exposed to
entrepreneurship if I wanted something
you know we were a middle-class family
my dad would say okay come work so from
a being a young kid I'd go to the flea
market with him start slinging some car
audio stereos or some
subwoofers or anything that was tied to
that so I'd bounce around at a very
young age six seven eight years old
interacting with adults and so I think
one of the things that that taught me is
it gave me an exposure to how to
interact with adults so a lot of people
have told me I'm very mature for my age
even at being young and in business you
know my mindset thinks in a more mature
day even now how do you know thirty
eight makes sense I've had that come up
in the last decade a lot more and I I
finally realized it was being in the
game so early yeah that's exactly what
it is and you know how to interact and
then you know it's it's emotional it's
like you know that EQ like when you go
it's you know interacting with people
reading people's behavior understanding
it then when you have salesmanship
behind it you're selling stuff so you
have to react and you know cater to
those you know for me it was radical
candor because I don't like negativity
yeah and because I'm willing to take on
everything yeah and like want the
pressure I the thing that I had to
really overcome from my natural skills
was radical candor I realized when I was
firing people at Wine Library in my 20s
they were shocked yeah and to me I was
upset at them at first which is a flaw
because I'm like bro you suck yeah
you've been sucking but then I realized
wait a minute they're not self-aware
that they suck and I've been telling
them everything's fine so I'm the dick
ya know I had the same I really
struggled with that yeah I had the same
problem you know there's like a
maturation process as the leader it even
so far as a few years back even being a
CEO you don't want to tell them they
suck because you're just like hoping
that they just finally [ __ ] get it
and they were gonna do you know for me
it's a lot of times I put them in the
right position yeah move people around
yeah you know like Seth used to do audio
I was like he sucks that's a no but like
no honestly like it's like it's fun for
my team because you guys know this like
finding the right spots
what really makes Vayner awesome I think
is back to Seth's point which is not
true it's that talent was growing and we
needed somebody strong and I felt like
and he wanted a new chat like was
awesome
like and whether it's by the way this is
like very meta very real now I'm not
even sure because I've been busy and we
haven't talked a lot lately I miss you a
little bit we should wrap ten minutes
how it's working or not but what I
even if it's a disaster and the reason
and like he doesn't like it but but he
likes me and he knows there's
opportunity here if he like did this and
like he came to me tomorrow I was like
hey I want to do something else would be
back I'm team Gary or go to whatever we
would work on and try to figure it out
what's really cool is eight years later
he'd be like you know what that was good
because I learned this during that time
there's things that Hurley he's learning
they're they right I can see by your
body language so I think it's optimism
its optimistic management if you can
afford it you may end up with somebody
who's a much better executive because
their learning context and all those
different I think that's what events
people don't want to fire yeah easy to
fire but I think that a lot of somebody
to quit a lot of people are afraid to
roll up their sleeves and actually you
know let let themselves be vulnerable in
those situations and actually look at it
as hey maybe I'm gonna learn something I
didn't learn before that'll be valuable
somewhere down the road
the biggest thing you feel like you want
to evolve next like what's on your mind
right now is an entrepreneurs the leader
is an executive that you're like you
know what over next decade I'd like to
be better at well I think you know when
you look at within the travel
hospitality space I just think it's
right for some sort of disruption I
think you have these influencers who are
out posting about properties and travel
where most of them can't afford it no
knock on on those that can so you're
saying you think we know this I mean
half the people watching me now are
aspiring to be a travel you know
influencer because everybody wants to
travel and like who wouldn't want to go
to Maui and stay in a five-star place
and just post a photo and call it a day
are you saying it's that they themselves
cannot or their audience doesn't have a
high percentage but I think I think it's
actually both there's there's a few that
can obviously that point that you're
razzing anyone you're saying that that
may not be a good business arbitrage for
that business because we're trying to
get awareness but if you're getting
awareness for something one that doesn't
convert you know it's not the right type
of clientele and so I think you know one
of the things that I've been focused on
is making luxury you know attainable and
so when you look at that everybody loses
context around what does that mean so
you have people in which you know some
people a four-star hotel is luxury than
to other people it has to be a five-star
in order for them to feel luxury in it
every every person is different and it's
around context to this day the most
luxury thing that I've ever felt was the
Holiday Inn in Orlando Florida when I
was ten years old because we'd never
spent a dollar on anything and going on
that vacation we stayed in the [ __ ]
Holiday Inn and I remember thinking how
fancy it was and like to this and I've
stayed in some places because of my
lifestyle and when you travel and you
speak they put you up in rooms that cuz
you know 20 it's one of the it's funny
what people spend money on I will right
now like this week I'm gonna spend
thousands of dollars buying custom
jerseys of random Jets players who will
barely play this year but with hotel
rooms I'm a very give me the bed I'm
shower pressure and Wi-Fi Wi-Fi is gonna
dirty room I'm fine all right just the
truth like it doesn't really register
like cockroach on Wi-Fi or if the shower
the shower pressure that's pretty
actually with your influence now in the
hotel space can we start getting more
data around can we create a
standardization around shower brush you
know and then they can show me on the
hotel room I know who actually tests
that you know who tests that Four
Seasons so I went to their headquarters
they literally have all the pipes there
so they test how loud it is so that the
room next to it because if you nobody
wants to hear water rushing through I do
the sound machine on and it's like I
could hear the shower
they might pressure number one they do
they test the pressure they do it but it
is a huge thing I would agree but I also
want to have hotel rooms now that don't
have the bulk of the bar in the room
like with a like sometimes I travel in
third you know kind of smaller cities
and it's one of those hotels where like
all the foods downstairs and I get
pumped because I know I don't eat dumb
[ __ ] yeah because I'm a dumb [ __ ] when
they like oh and you have like the gummy
bears sitting there weird things about
eating gummy bears is the bet you have
to make with yourself if they're
actually soft it's true cuz if they're
stale right and they're scary you like
this is the worst unhealthy disordered
I've made
I knew I should have went with the app
like $42 exactly and if his still you
leave him behind but then you take up
because you feel guilty the great
decisions that are not talked about
enough which is the decision to buy
gummy bears predicated on not really
knowing if they're soft enough is
anybody here a hard gummy bear fever no
nothing else you are doing it you like
them hard versus soft we're happy to
send you all the shitty gummy bears
chewy chewy soft you got away yeah the
harder ones but though but the but
sometimes they come across if they're
stale they're called hard like they like
you got actually good business idea I
think gummy bears should do a pop-up
like a pop-up truck where they're making
them on the spot I [ __ ] wait mine for
that sure sure
hot gummy saw be cool but soft this I'm
a softest [ __ ] gummy bear claw super
let's do phone clearly being here
we've DV if you're watching LinkedIn put
your phone number in if you have a
question for plan I and anything about
the hospitality space entrepreneurship
the flip life because I guess we both
live that who's this gummy bears well
alex is Gary Vaynerchuk how's it going
area oh my god
how are you please say hello to Faisal
hey are you good how are you I'm really
good
what can we answer for you brother um so
crazy I I work in hospitality I I'm in
medicine and I do house calls to all the
hotels in Los Angeles when their guests
are sick interesting and I'm leaving
traditional medicine to do that really
come made me wonder about the concepts
of hospitality as a whole in traditional
business and kind of there's an
hospitality it's really about treating
people
with the highest level of service that
you can so I feel like that's sort of
missing in traditional business and I
just kind of wanted what your thoughts
on that work yeah I mean for for me
personally I think you're right but I
think that you're seeing worlds
colliding with in all different
industries around creating an experience
you know that's centered around
hospitality you have fitness brand you
have hotel brands coming into fitness
fitness brands going into hotels you
know if you look at hotels and concierge
doctors or even dentists you I was
sitting with my wife she's telling me
there are offices where it's kind of a
spa so everyone traditionally hates
going to the dentist you go in there and
you can get a pedicure like while you're
while you're getting your teeth drilled
on I guess what I think though you know
for for somebody like yourself you know
it is all about the guest experience and
taking care of people in whatever
industry that you're in and if you're
focused on you know your customer at the
end of the day and doing everything to
ensure that they're taken care of
you have now you're creating that unique
hospitable experience that you build a
real business around yeah I mean look I
wrote a book called the Thank You
economy in 2011 that has undertones of
your questions brother I think I think
that businesses if everybody thought
they were in the hospitality business
and then they sold you know concrete and
then they sold wine and then they sold
salads and then they made sneakers you
would I actually think it's one of the
best arbitrage as to building a brand
for shoes I mean everybody who's
watching right now who's an influencer
if they just randomly diem25 followers
right now and ask for their address and
then sent a wink and said it's a
surprise and sent them all some sort of
basket with a handwritten note that
would be better for their influence or
business but people don't think that way
yeah no I agree that that's kind of what
helps me become successful in a short
period of time because you know when
you're the to the doctor or to the
hospital you know you're just kind of
there to be to figure out what's wrong
and good get a prescription or whatever
but when you really really have the
hospitality mindset of trying to take
care of people and do everything you can
to make it more of an experience and
just a quick in-and-out and I get into
what I need then empathy as well that
that
it's smart brother it's super smart I
think you should write more LinkedIn
posts about your thoughts on this
because it could lead to other
opportunities keep that in mind you know
look I think it's a really interesting
question I mean I think you know when I
think about you and what I know about
you and I think about myself
it goes into a very interesting well
Raghav poses it up I think we were born
entrepreneurs and we were trained
entrepreneurs and the reality is me
being in the wine business you mean a
hotel business mean being in marketing
you know it really was agnostic it was
serendipitous it doesn't matter I mean I
was in finance mortgages before so
that's right I know and I think if you
if I run it you know if we run into each
other in airport in nine years because
obviously we got busy and more
communicating and you're like yo I've
got a huge you know like you know beef
jerky business in my mind I'd be like
yep yeah and I kind of the way I think
about entrepreneurship is how I think
about hospitality like just cuz you're
in the hotel business or things that
nature hospitality is an oxygen it's a
mindset
it's a culture and it can be deployed
against everything yeah and people
actually are attracted to it they
gravitate towards it inspires gonna miss
his big chance hello this is Alex Brown
at the Charles mom ranch I'm unable to
answer my phone right now but please
leave a message and I will contact you
as soon as possible thank you very much
at the tone please record your message
when you've finished recording you may
hang up or press one for more options
Alec Brown this is Gary Vaynerchuk you
[ __ ] up you know you did not answer
the phone call and you will be calling
back like everybody else who [ __ ] up on
this show but we will not be answering
it because everything in life is about
timing I wish you great health and
happiness
yeah by the way I think a lot about what
just happened to like one of the great
things about entrepreneurship is people
always ask me what mistakes have you
made and I always talk about my uber
passing through the phone but you know
20 I know the biggest mistake I ever
made was cancelling a meeting I was
about to have that
have been the Domino piece to make
everything work you know we've all done
that don't you just go about it together
and I cancel some pretty fancy [ __ ]
meetings but I also think it's the
unfastens that you just know Patrick
Patrick it's Gary Vaynerchuk and you're
on with Faisal how are you doing good
guys how you guys doing well hey thank
you all right so the question is I have
two businesses one where I do graphics
media photography videography locally
for local businesses and I also do
printing the biggest problem that I have
is bridging that gap between basically
working on my own work to cry self at
that finally starting to hire an
executive it existed a printing manager
or somebody what kind of formula would
you consider or even like think about
and you know what what is your
foundation in which you feel like you
need to have prior to getting that first
person to help you offload a lot of the
work to continue progressing forward
so before advise up another physical
first but I just want to hear it because
I was asking rag off something I might
have missed one point you're telling me
the challenge at hand is actually just
scaling your business
like literally hiring and off and and
letting go of certain things and
understanding how to you know manage
that and afford it and just the whole
strategy of like of scaling yeah
essentially essentially that it's the
biggest thing is like getting that one
person to come on well and in getting
that one person to base because I know I
the next step is to basically get
additional people in to help me offload
the work that I currently have to
continue growing but what are the basic
things that you would you would say that
you require before getting that first
person to come on yeah
first and foremost you have to be able
to within 2 minutes or less articulate
your vision like you're explaining it to
your grandma that's first and foremost
like you have to have what are you doing
or what you think you're doing that can
change and iterate a thousand different
times along the way but you can't you
you know I think it's incredibly
reckless to bring somebody in without
any sort of path or vision for what
you're trying to build and
and to be honest with you what's in it
for them you know at the end of the day
the next thing is I will add one point
to that I think that was big business
talk I'm like a little bit of a start-up
in a bigger thing like yeah to answer
your question what you know to add to
that because I think that's right but at
his scale what's in it for the other
person is whatever they're getting paid
yeah yeah but I don't know what I mean
it's also come with me I'm starting it
up like you got a they've got to be
excited to come in and a one-person job
yeah I definitely you know I definitely
have revenue I have profit things like
that the biggest things I would say that
I have the biggest concerns is you know
I don't have storefront just yeah things
like that
so you know we would be working
satellite together for for a while until
like you to that next yeah that's
actually more fun most of the time why
do you have to work satellite because
everything that I basically do is out of
my own home right now okay and what what
do you want the first employee to do the
first employee
I would I would have to say would be
client management while I continue to
sell because that's what I do
so what's stopping you from hiring her
him now biggest thing is honestly making
sure that I have enough profit margin to
consistently pay one one person to take
care of my current clients so I can go
ahead and keep selling it makes sense
good where you like it what is your
consideration of percentage or anything
like that we would you get there's no
right answer now there's only your
actual path you know so what I would say
by that is you know do you have a sense
of how much that person costs do you
have that much profit in the last 12
months and what are you doing with your
money that you're taking out of the
business if you are so let's go through
that are you thinking are you is this
drawing a salary you've anything yeah so
basically it's just paying my fair bit
of our bill that's that's basically what
it's paying yeah and this is all you do
right this
like percent yeah I quit my job six
months ago this is all I do have any
debt no so your debt free human yeah and
right now you're at exactly bare minute
like the Bislett I'm gonna make this up
without prying the business does go
64,000 and top-line revenue and because
it makes you 40,000 profit because there
is nothing you're selling it's just your
time and you live afford exactly $40,000
a year lifetime lifestyle pretty car
okay so there's a couple things one I
want to know what's in that forty
thousand right because one of the things
that when my friends say those things to
me and they let me look at every single
thing or somebody that really wants my
help and shows me everything inevitably
everyone's got a little more cush than
they realize because somehow people
think certain things are required and
they're not and you know literally
literally look I mean you know I kind of
live this lifestyle for a big part of my
you know 20s the only expense I had was
car gas food and roof I literally didn't
but like literally liquor t-shirts from
the store was Mike my outfits and
literally there was no entertainment
cost involved and and that's why I was
able to hire people because I was able
to live on thirty seven thousand dollars
a year I think you've got a decision to
make one go super hard and create that
growth yourself and wait another year or
two you could take on debt you could I
hate it I hate it but what I really am
excited about just kind of even going on
vibes is if you do hire that person to
do a lot of the defense [ __ ] it lets you
go on the offense and your growth
accelerates even greater than your costs
do you see what I mean exactly I mean
the first place you have to look is your
lifestyle costs right and is there
anything you could do to go more humble
if you really put your business ahead of
yourself I've put my businesses ahead of
myself every day of my life in my career
which is why I built huge businesses
most people think they build businesses
so they can buy [ __ ] from the business
and they take from the business I feed
the business yeah and it sounds like
you're going that path now the question
becomes
how much shittier can your lifestyle be
if you want to get there faster units
not forever but you gotta you gotta
buckle down if you want it more weight
right was it like like uh I actually I
haven't but I actually haven't thought I
have a thought to where if you have if
you have the ability to hire somebody
and you have the margins that are there
or at least like close to I I had one
investor when I was one of my companies
that had started La Jolla wealth
management in San Diego as a mortgage
finance company and we were about to
take on a lease that was a little bit
pricey but in order to be in the area to
attract the clients we had to do it you
know what she told me she said sometimes
being stretched and putting your at your
ass and back against the wall is the
best thing to motivate you to excel even
further and she was right like I took on
a little bit more than I could chew in
order you know to build the business and
it forced you because every day you're
more hungry because you're scared of not
being able to pay that person there's no
math equation that like there's you know
people do it this is why people think
you go to school for business and they
say the proper thing is 32.3% your
[ __ ] that's fine that's not real life
that's like thesis yeah right answer
your questions very simple you're at the
crossroads either you take on debt or
you raise capital that gives you money
to be able to hire Susan orth
or Jonathan or you wait another year and
go slower save even more create more
margin bleed a little more to be able to
feel comfortable that you'll be you know
six months runway on a salary that you
can pay and then you go on the offense
to close that gap does that make sense
absolutely it's as simple as that and
you can do it and and by the way there
is no right way of those two those are
the alternatives the the only other
alternative is your your overhead of
your lifestyle is far greater than bare
bone and you cut into that right that's
it those are the three moves three moves
in this scenario grow it grow the
business a little bit more save some
cash you do exactly the other two things
I mean that's it so by the way and this
is where it gets you know there's never
that's it you could borrow fifty
thousand bucks from your uncle
you could mm-hmm you could yeah uh you
could sell all the [ __ ] [ __ ] in your
home on Facebook marketplace at eBay and
make 5,000 extra month on the side you
could I mean there should to be done
there's there's a sacrifice either way
like you just got to pick which one you
want to you want to go with and then
double down and just go with it
I think I'm super offensive and so
because I'm super offense they're
probably just gonna dive into it and
yeah and use be the uncle with $50,000
as a okay now my ass is really in the
fire and maybe this is a good time to
borrow so I think I'm going to go with
option a you know just just just throw
it down and and start selling more and
loud person to play defense on the back
end and then if I really bet on yourself
I like bet on yourself like it awesome
okay good luck brother
see ya thank you brother anything you
want to talk about believe that we'd get
to yeah I mean you know a lot of lot of
interesting things coming from the the
content side within our business and
what we're looking to do started our
podcast business class business class
it's on the on the podcast you'll see
business class you'll see what do people
expect from that so it's actually really
interesting it's not just travel related
we do talk about travel with almost
every guest just to get their unique
insights of where they've been
but really it's different entrepreneurs
that have come from all walks of life
and just done some interesting things
so we've shot now twelve we've launched
we've launched seven of them so the best
guest I'm putting you directly on a spot
this will hurt eleven other humans
feelings ah it's okay one exactly yeah
yeah so I mean I had to so one guy vibed
with completely well Michael chernow who
you had on here I mean he's awesome who
we he's a dope dude the other one who's
super interesting another buddy of mine
is Matt Goss so that one hasn't aired
yet but he has an interesting you know
he's an artist so they're always
interesting better show of the - I mean
like vibing I think it's aa sure now
alright that's a no yeah it's there it's
live let's wipe up I'll put it on
later at the hotel bars on IG the number
you have dialed is not in service
[Laughter]
you know I do have a funny baseball card
as baseball card story already
so I remember I was working at the Napa
flea market for my dad as eight years
old and I had a bo Jackson rookie card
and so yeah so football 88 football
football 88 tops so you know we're going
and working through there go to try and
buy some cards from you know the local
car dealers at the flea market well the
guy took advantage of me traded like a
Michael Jordan card and here which were
not as valuable whatever and that was
like a young kid that got pushed over by
an adult and took it so I went back then
after he taught me a lesson so I was
like this guy ripped me off dad so he
goes let's go talk to him so he had him
go card by card and look it up and the
value of it so it was not in my favor
yes and you know I thought oh my dad's
gonna make him give it to me back and
basically my dad said now you know
control and manage your assets take care
of them for the rest of your life so and
I mean he let me walk away with the [ __ ]
end of the stick
what is great what I don't like 98%
appearance now that want to fight on
behalf of the kid oh yeah he was like
you exactly it's okay I'm still here I'm
alive Alex Alex
no [ __ ] scary been Faisal how are you
how are you good how are you guys
we're doing well what's your question
alright I'm kind of like third podcasted
Smith on my talking about my community
in the local businesses okay I was just
wondering if that's possible it is do
you live in America I lived in the okay
I'm watching good small the answer is
it's possible okay so should I just like
start with like yep the small
or less yes small I'm all around you
your network start building it Alex let
me ask you a question
are you looking for affirmation are you
help me help you
like the interest are you asking if it's
a good idea like tell me what you're
doing here right now the answer is yes
how old are you at 25 awesome and you're
and you're doing this because you want
to be an entrepreneur and you've heard
me or others talk about podcasts /local
and you you're putting the pieces
together and you're like you can see a
world where you're interviewing local
businesses are people like you feel good
about that yeah I think that'd be great
to get like local businesses that we
have out there and good and and is your
concern that it's too narrow and you
might not get enough ad revenue and then
the sit at some point wondering yeah so
let me give you an answer the answer is
yes now that I've asked those questions
here's why one you need the experience
and thinking about it is never better
than doing it okay yeah that's number
one number two if you do it well even
though your podcast might not be that
monetizable though the local Chamber of
Commerce and a 1500 bucks and 2500 bucks
from all the local businesses could add
up to a nice little fifty to a hundred
thousand dollar revenue business what
more likely happen is that you do it
well and you start a business because
all the local businesses ask you to do
their podcast and now you've built a
five hundred thousand dollar business
being a service provider do you see what
I mean
action leads opportunity and I want to
like video I have video so I understand
I understand he also builds builds a
network of people that could lead I mean
what I always think is there there's a
network to where if you have positive
intent you know you're trying
of course you personally are trying to
build your podcast but if you're digging
deep into these entrepreneurs and
providing value and exposure for them
whether they're millionaires or just
starting their businesses they're going
to feel this little inkling of I owe
this kid something and then all the
sudden
there may be the opportunity and you
know them and have built a rapport with
them and they trust you and or they may
be your first investor to the business
that you come up with as well Alex are
you are you dating or married yeah I'm
married right now okay awesome that
eliminates the other ROI from this gonna
be the fun picture of like actual life
where you could have met your wife but
nonetheless take another story let me
tell you why I was gonna go down that
path and I asked you that question
mm-hmm doing always beats thinking yeah
totally the end
and I mean our phone call was almost you
know luckily I was in the mood but there
was a part of me that was like halfway
home to just hanging up on you because
in a good way just being yes and that's
it to make a point for the audience and
to you we're sticking out a little
calmer today but like it's yes do it bro
just do it I don't mean you're in
[ __ ] Nike country just do it you're
in the Pacific Northwest you guys
understand that [ __ ] motto just
[ __ ] make like all this over yeah
like I I'm just so tired of everybody
overthinking whether it was the best use
of your time or not actually doing it is
better like people spend so much time
debating that even if they would have
done the wrong thing they they still had
more time on their hand I like doing and
finding out I'm wrong and still saving
time everyone so values their time or
they're so insecure about people judging
their decision that they don't [ __ ]
me by not doing the only thing you're
gonna have is regret that you didn't and
when you start doing it you get positive
feedback you're gonna be like [ __ ] I
should have done this a year ago and I
dialed it and when you do it and you
[ __ ] suck at it you've now realized
you've built on your self-awareness
you're like I'm not a [ __ ] podcaster
next yeah exactly nothing more like
edits on my Instagram and like I started
doing the join Gary being doing that
it's on no it's like thinking practice
on that nice and just really just trying
to get more out there and build
something that like my community doesn't
have or like even the nice that they
don't have make make me I love it
yeah go make thank you guys thanks for
be on the show bro huh thank you good
times yeah always go there and now in
Spokane you get to ask a question of the
day any question you want all right
seeing that I work in the travel
industry if you could travel to one
place for the rest of your life where
would you go MetLife Stadium you keep
asking questions we'll keep answering
them